[Musik]
>> MURAT: Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Dam-da-dam-da-daa!
Oh, die Wurst!
Sally! Wasser!
Sally!
>> SALLY: Murat!
>> MURAT: Feuer!
Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
>> SALLY: Murat, ernsthaft?!
>> MURAT: Herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt!
Heute wieder was ganz Besonderes.
Weil wir haben schon lang mit dem Güni
kein Video mehr gemacht.
Und der Zeit geschuldet natürlich.
Während alle
– Sally die ganze Zeit gekocht hat,
waren der Güni und ich auf der Baustelle
und haben gearbeitet.
Deswegen hat es lange keine Videos gegeben.
Und heute fangen wir wieder an.
Und jetzt dürfen wir ihn begrüßen.
Hier. Ihr kennt ihn. Interpol kennt ihn.
Güni.
So.
[Jubel]
Schön, Güni.
>> GÜNTER: Hallo, mein Freund!
>> MURAT: Nein, nicht so nah!
Bitte nicht so nah. Wir müssen Abstand halten.
>> GÜNTER: Ach so.
>> MURAT: Wir haben zwar
– weil wir zusammenarbeiten schon seit Jahren,
>> GÜNTER: Geh mal weiter rüber.
>> MURAT: Ja.
haben wir...
>> GÜNTER: Noch ein Stück bitte.
>> MURAT: Ja, sag mal. Hör auf jetzt.
So. Auf jeden Fall haben wir den Abstand,
der Güni, was sein muss.
Und wir haben lange nicht mehr zusammen gearbeitet,
weil du bist ja ein Risikopatient, richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und zwar, weil der Güni
ist ein Risiko für uns alle.
Und deswegen
waren wir eigentlich nicht die ganze Zeit hier, richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Darf man dann eine Messerattacke vortäuschen?
>> MURAT: Weil Corona musste ja erst
Antikörper gegen dich bilden.
>> GÜNTER: Ach, gegen mich?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Hm.
>> MURAT: So. Okay.
Auf jeden Fall, wir sind gesund.
Ich bin gesund.
>> GÜNTER: Das kann man sehen, wie man will.
>> MURAT: So. Aha?
Wir sind ja bekannt für herzhafte Gerichte. Genau.
Richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Ja, man sieht es.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall
herzhafte Gerichte.
Wir machen was...
>> GÜNTER: Vielleicht wäre mal was so ein Müsli.
Ein Müsli auch
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> GÜNTER: mit Quark und
>> MURAT: Nein!
>> GÜNTER: Joghurt für dich.
>> MURAT: Nee. Die nennen...
Übrigens, Güni, die nennen das nicht mehr Müsli.
Die nennen das jetzt so ein bisschen Englisch.
Die nennen das jetzt Porridge.
[Windgeräusche]
Das ist dann
– hört sich dann cooler an.
>> GÜNTER: Aha.
>> MURAT: Porridge.
>> GÜNTER: Aha. Weißt du, wie man das schreiben?
>> MURAT: Nee.
Und es werden ja
– viele Begriffe werden ja inzwischen
eigentlich so englisch gemacht,
dass es sich einfach cooler anhört.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja. Früher hieß das ja...
Es heißt
– kennst du das Wort Influencer?
Weißt du, was das ist?
>> GÜNTER: Ja, da, wenn man Grippe kriegt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja. Nein.
Aber ein Influencer ist
–  früher hieß es einfach nur Hauptschüler.
[Tusch]
>> GÜNTER: Und du bist Baumschüler?
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
>> GÜNTER: Ein Baum-Influencer.
>> MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall...
>> GÜNTER: Ein Baumfluencer bist du.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Güni und ich sind beste Freunde schon seit Jahren.
>> GÜNTER: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Doch, das stimmt. 13 Jahre.
>> GÜNTER: Wir kennen uns.
>> MURAT: Wir haben heute unseren...
>> GÜNTER: Nein!
>> MURAT: Ja, doch. Heute auf den Tag
haben wir unseren 13. Jahrestag. Weißt du das?
Es ist sehr, sehr freundschaftlich.
Die Beleidigungen, die wir uns an den Kopf werfen,
sind eigentlich sehr lieb gemeint.
Habe ich recht?
Ja.
Und Güni ist ein guter Freund von mir,
weil er schlecht sieht und schlecht hört.
>> GÜNTER: Hä?
>> MURAT: Und deswegen sind wir gute Freunde. Ja.
Nicht weiter aufhalten lassen.
Wir machen heute eine richtig coole Holzfällerpfanne.
Das Ding heißt Holzfällerpfanne, weil...
>> GÜNTER: Hast du mal Holz gefällt?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Hast du schon mal Holz gefällt?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja?
Weil du auf der Baumschule warst.
[Tusch]
Die Videos sind auf einem geringen Bildungsniveau.
>> GÜNTER: Halt, halt, halt, halt. Wie soll das gehen?
>> MURAT: Wieso?
>> GÜNTER: Geh mal rüber.
>> MURAT: Okay, okay.
>> GÜNTER: Du bist mir zu nah.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
Oh, ich fange schon an zu schwitzen.
So.
Am liebsten hätte ich gern so einen Taser,
wo ich dir an Ding...
Stell dir mal vor, jemand kommt
und der Güni kommt in den Raum rein
und müsste dann Temperatur messen
und dann ist es plötzlichen ein Elektrotaser.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Das Bild!
O Gott! Das Bild! Ich würde das so feiern.
Ich würde das teilen. Auf jeden Fall.
>> GÜNTER: Ach ja?
>> MURAT: #GüniWurdeGetasert.
Auf jeden Fall
geht es weiter.
Wir haben hier ganz, ganz tolle Zutaten
und zwar ganz einfache Zutaten wirklich,
die man wirklich überall bekommt.
Richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Weil Güni und ich haben nämlich ein Ding,
was wir immer sagen:
Jedes Rezept muss aus Zutaten bestehen,
die wir auch schreiben können.
Richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Kannst du?
>> MURAT: Das ist auch immer ganz spannend gewesen.
>> GÜNTER: Kannst du alles schreiben?
>> MURAT: Ich kann alles schreiben.
>> GÜNTER: Schreib mal To-
– buchstabier mal Tomatenmark.
>> MURAT: T-O-M-A-T-E-N-
Mark M-A-R-K.
Aber zusammengeschrieben. Groß.
>> GÜNTER: Nicht ck?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Nein.
So. Auf jeden Fall...
So.
>> GÜNTER: Der überlegt noch immer,
noch mal überlegen.
>> MURAT: Nee.
>> GÜNTER: Okay,
>> MURAT: Ich habe immer Angst...
>> GÜNTER: war richtig. War richtig.
Hey, du bist gut.
>> MURAT: Danke schön.
Ja, ich habe bei dir immer Angst,
dass ich in eine Falle reintrete.
Du stellst mich immer hin, he.
Du stellst mir manchmal richtig hinterlistige Fallen.
>> GÜNTER: Nein, nein, nein, nein.
>> MURAT: Doch, doch, doch, doch.
>> GÜNTER: Du hast doch gesagt, ich wäre dumm.
>> MURAT: Ja, echt? Aber ich habe...
>> GÜNTER: Alter!
>> MURAT: Ich habe das nicht behauptet,
aber andere sagen das.
>> GÜNTER: Ach, das sagen andere? Du nicht?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich nicht.
Auf jeden Fall nicht das Video in die Länge ziehen.
Wir sind schon bei Minute 4 wahrscheinlich
und haben noch nicht mal...
Die Leute, wissen nur, dass wir eine Holzfällerpfanne
– -topf machen.
Einen Holzfällertopf machen wir.
Genau, deftig.
Und dazu haben wir die Zutaten
und die Zutaten, die zeige ich euch mal jetzt.
So.
Das Erste, was wir brauchen, ist
vier Liter Olivenöl.
>> GÜNTER: Wie viel?
>> MURAT: Vier Liter
– vier Esslöffel.
Vier Esslöffel Olivenöl.
>> GÜNTER: Vier Esslöffel
>> MURAT: Ah!
>> GÜNTER: Olivenöl.
Und 1.000 Gramm.
>> MURAT: Ich wollte nur testen, ob du lesen kannst.
>> GÜNTER: 100 Gramm.
>> MURAT: So.
Also wir brauchen Olivenöl
von der Heide meiner
– von der Olivenheide meiner Mutter.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Was? Heide?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Haine.
>> MURAT: Haine heißt das?
Also wir brauchen vier Esslöffel Olivenöl
von den Hainen meiner Mutter,
>> GÜNTER: Was?
>> MURAT: Olivenhainen meiner Mutter.
Wie heißt das?
Du bist so blöd!
Das heißt doch
– heißt das Haine oder Heide?
>> GÜNTER: Hain.
Hain. Hain.
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> GÜNTER: Hainheide.
>> MURAT: Nein.
Oliven-
Aylin, wie schreibt man das?
Alles klar. Noch mal.
>> GÜNTER: Wie wird Olivenhain geschrieben?
>> MURAT: Mit H-A-I-N.
>> GÜNTER: Weiter.
>> MURAT: Hain.
>> GÜNTER: Und Olive?
>> MURAT: O-L-I-ve.
O mein Gott!
>> GÜNTER: Der kann nicht mal...
>> MURAT: Ja, ich würde am liebsten meinen Kopf da reintun
und dann hier
>> GÜNTER: O ja, mach!
>> MURAT: und viermal ziehen.
>> GÜNTER: Ja! Mach, mach, mach, mach!
Komm her. Ich mache es.
Was?
>> MURAT: Vier Esslöffel Olivenöl.
Dann haben wir 1.000 Gramm Rindergulasch.
Dann haben wir hier zwei Zwiebeln,
zwei glückliche Knoblauchzehen,
80 Gramm Tomatenmark.
Habe ich gerade in Tomatenmark reingefasst?
So. Okay.
Auf jeden Fall...
>> GÜNTER: Das kann man nicht mehr nehmen.
>> MURAT: Dann haben wir fünf Möhren.
So. Dann haben wir hier
so was wie eine BiFi, nur halt türkisch.
So. Eine türkische BiFi,
BüFö.
>> GÜNTER: BüFö...
>> MURAT: So.
Auf jeden Fall....
>> GÜNTER: BüFö!
>> MURAT: Und dann haben wir hier
400 Gramm Champignons.
Das sind Kulturchampignons.
>> GÜNTER: Was für eine?
>> MURAT: Kultur, die haben Kultur.
Die sind...
Du bist ja kulturlos. Das ist was anderes.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Ach so. Das, was du nicht hast?
>> MURAT: Ja, genau. Kultur, genau.
>> GÜNTER: Ah.
>> MURAT: Dann haben wir hier Drillinge.
Was sind das? Kartoffeln.
Also auch 500 Gramm Drillinge aus der Pfalz.
>> GÜNTER: Drillinge ist eine Kartoffelart, nicht?
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> GÜNTER: Das musst sagen.
>> MURAT: Dann haben 800...
Dann haben wir 800 Gramm Wasser.
>> GÜNTER: Wie viel?
>> MURAT: 800 Gramm.
>> GÜNTER: Milliliter.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> GÜNTER: Milliliter!
[Zeitraffer]
>> MURAT: Ich bin voll der liebe Mensch. Wirklich.
Ich bin ein froh-
Morgens wache ich auf,
sehe meine wunderhübsche Frau neben mir liegen.
Und dann kommen meine zwei kleinen Kinder,
die küsse ich dann.
Und ich habe ein wunderschönes Familienleben.
Und dann mache ich morgens die Tür auf
und habe einen Kaffee in der Hand und alles ist schön.
Und dann sehe ich den vor mir.
So. Und dann gehen die Aggressionen in mir hoch.
Dann habe ich Blutdruck.
Dann habe ich ein Völlegefühl.
Dann habe ich...
>> GÜNTER: Ja, das kommt aber...
Das kommt aber nicht von mir, das Völlegefühl.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Das kannst du mir jetzt nicht erzählen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und denke ich mir: "Warum?"
>> GÜNTER: Sei ruhig.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
So.
Dann haben wir hier natürlich
auch noch ein paar coole Zutaten.
Dann haben wir hier noch Tomaten aus der Dose.
Da könnt ihr wirklich Tomaten aus der Dose neben,
weil es kann ja sein,
dass es gerade keine Tomaten frisch gibt
vom Strauch.
>> GÜNTER: Im Winter.
>> MURAT: Im Winter, genau.
Es kann ja sein, dass ja gerade Winter ist.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, ja, ja.
>> MURAT: Momentan ist gerade...
>> GÜNTER: Wir haben gerade Sommer.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT & GÜNTER: Aber
>> MURAT: vielleicht haben wir auch Winter gerade.
Wir wissen es nicht.
So.
Dann haben wir zwei Lorbeerblätter.
Dann haben wir Rauchsalz.
Also das hat nichts mit Zigarettenrauch zu tun.
Dann haben wir hier Kreuzkümmel.
Dann haben wir Paprika edelsüß.
Und dann haben wir noch Oregano.
Und dann haben wir noch
Kreuzkümmel, noch mal Kreuzkümmel.
>> GÜNTER: Nee, das war Pfeffer.
>> MURAT: Ah, das war Pfeffer. Ja, stimmt. Genau.
Pfeffer.
Geschmack.
Zu den Zutaten.
Ansonsten die Gewürze,
da habe ich euch keine Grammzahlen genannt.
Das ist so
– wirklich, das müsst ihr mögen.
>> GÜNTER: Das muss man abschmecken.
>> MURAT: Das muss man abschmecken. Genau.
Kreuzkümmel ist für mich
– gehört in den Eintopf dazu.
Das ist so
– weißt du, wie Kreuzkümmel riecht?
>> GÜNTER: Nee.
>> MURAT: Hast du schon mal deinen Turnbeutel
mal drei Tage
– drei Wochen lang im Ding vergessen?
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Im Kofferraum?
>> GÜNTER: Warte mal.
O ja, jetzt weiß ich, wie Kreuzkümmel riecht.
Oh!
>> MURAT: Da fällt mir gerade ein Witz ein.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Nein. Hör auf mit deinen Witzen.
>> MURAT: Nein. Pass auf.
>> GÜNTER: Nein!
>> MURAT: Oh, der war echt gut!
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Nee, den erzähle ich nicht.
Der war nicht...
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Den könnte ich erzählen,
wenn die Kamera aus ist.
>> GÜNTER: Ich habe mir es gleich gedacht.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
Auf jeden Fall fangen wir an.
Das Erste, was wir machen:
Wir haben zwar das Fleisch
– übrigens Haltungsform 5.
4 ist Bio. 5 ist?
5 ist?
>> GÜNTER: Bio.
>> MURAT: Nein. 5 ist Bio und 5 ist,
wenn du sogar noch den Namen des Tieres kennst.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, wie hieß
>> MURAT: Gustav.
>> GÜNTER: das Tier? Gustav?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: War das nicht eine weibliche Kuh?
>> MURAT: Nee, mach das...
Nein. Egal.
>> GÜNTER: Freiland?
>> MURAT: Ja, Freiland. Richtig Freiland unter freiem Land
oder im freien Land mit einem Pass.
So. Auf jeden Fall hier...
>> GÜNTER: Hast du einen Pass?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Doch, einen türkischen.
Du bist so doof.
So. Auf jeden Fall...
Kannst du mal...
Sag mal. Kann das sein, dass du immer was gegen meinen...
>> GÜNTER: Nein!
>> MURAT: Doch.
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Egal, wo wir sind...
>> GÜNTER: Komm.
>> MURAT: Doch egal, wo wir sind, egal, wo ich mit ihm bin,
der spricht mich immer darauf an,
ob ich einen deutschen Pass habe.
Ist dir das schon mal aufgefallen?
>> GÜNTER: Mhm.
>> MURAT: Und wenn 50 Menschen da sind,
sagst du: "Hast du einen deutschen Pass?"
Du weißt immer
– weil du weißt ja die Antwort.
Du weißt ja, dass ich keinen habe, oder?
>> GÜNTER: Ehrlich nicht?
>> MURAT: Nein, habe ich nicht.
>> GÜNTER: Das habe ich jetzt nicht gewusst.
[Tusch]
>> MURAT: Du bist so bescheuert!
Das ist doch...
Wirklich.
Mein Gott, he!
>> GÜNTER: Doch, das habe ich echt nicht gewusst.
Ich gehe.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall haben wir schon
in mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten.
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Doch.
>> LOUIS: Oh!
>> GÜNTER: Das muss noch mal geteilt werden.
>> MURAT: Genau, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Kannst du es bitte teilen?
Und zwar ganz einfach.
Du machst das einfach
so.
Siehst du das?
Und dann kannst du es ein bisschen kleiner schneiden.
Weil Gulasch,
das ist ein bisschen zu groß.
Okay.
Das machst du übrigens
– machst du gerade...
>> GÜNTER: Lass das hier mal stehen.
Da kann man es wieder reinschmeißen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> GÜNTER: Das geht.
Fünf Stunden später.
Das dauert seine Zeit.
>> MURAT: Sag mal. Tust du gerade Fleisch schneiden
oder meditierst du?
>> GÜNTER: A-a-a!
Das muss man mit Liebe machen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Nicht so husch, husch wie du.
>> MURAT: So. Während Güni das macht,
mache ich was ganz Cooles und zwar
– ich brauche eine Schüssel.
So. Während Güni hier schneidet,
mache ich auch meine Schnibbelarbeit.
Und zwar nehmt ihr Champignons.
Bei Champignons ist ganz, ganz wichtig:
Viele mal den Fehler, die wässern den Champignon.
Das heißt, die putzen den mit Wasser.
Nicht gut, weil der saugt auf Wasser wie ein Schwamm.
Das ist wie Güni.
Er saugt Fett auf wie ein Schwamm.
Und wie gesagt, solche Champignons
bitte nur mit einem feuchten Tuch ein bisschen abwischen.
Genau.
Jetzt nehme ich das gerade so,
mache immer zack.
So. Jetzt stopfe ich die rein.
Siehst du das, Güni, wie ich das mache?
Die Champignons einfach vierteln.
[Musik]
So. Wusstest du eigentlich
– während ich das gerade mache,
wir reden ja miteinander, gell?
Also pass auf.
Wusstest du eigentlich, dass
die Türkei Panzer baut?
Wusstest du das?
>> GÜNTER: Ich habe mir es gedacht,
als ich dich das letzte Mal gesehen habe.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Gelächter]
Oh, danke. Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Aber war voll nett von dir.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall
>> GÜNTER: Ich bin so.
>> MURAT: der türkische Panzer, der hat ja...
Der hat ja drei Vorwärtsgang,
also schnell, sehr schnell, superschnell.
>> GÜNTER: Und 28 Rückwärtsgänge.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So. Jetzt hast du mir den Witz geklaut, gell?
>> GÜNTER: Hahahaha.
>> MURAT: So.
>> GÜNTER: So. Die Salami auch schneiden?
>> MURAT: Ja, Güni.
>> GÜNTER: In?
>> MURAT: In Scheiben.
Aber halt nicht zu dünn.
Weil ich finde es cool, weil die nicht so Ding sind. Genau.
So.
>> GÜNTER: So? Guck mal.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Gefällt dir das so.
>> MURAT: Genau, das ist cool.
Und man kann halt verschiedene Wurst nehmen,
also die, worauf man Bock hat.
Man kann auch zum Beispiel Krakauer nehmen.
Oder man kann auch eine Thüringer Wurst nehmen
oder wie auch immer.
>> GÜNTER: Hä? Thüringer?
>> MURAT: Ja. Kennst du nicht?
Thüringen ist ganz bekannt für ihre Würste.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, für Bratwurst.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
>> GÜNTER: Die kannst du aber doch nicht
in ein Gulasch reinmachen.
>> MURAT: Doch, kannst du machen.
>> GÜNTER: Hä?
>> MURAT: Kannst du machen.
>> GÜNTER: Wo hast du denn das gesehen?
>> MURAT: Ich habe mir das nur ausgedacht.
>> GÜNTER: Wie viele Würste? Alle vier?
>> MURAT: Ja, alle vier finde ich cool.
So. Jetzt habe ich die Champignons gewürfelt.
Was du auch machen kannst, Güni,
genau, nachdem du die Wurst geschnitten hast:
Du kannst die Karotten schneiden.
Du kannst sie würfeln.
Okay?
Hast du schon mal Karotten gewürfelt?
Da gibt es auch ein Gerät dafür.
Aber bis ich das gefunden habe in der Küche...
So.
Und
>> GÜNTER: Jetzt warte doch mal.
>> MURAT: die Karotten, auch ganz wichtig:
Alles, was wir verwenden, ist bio.
Einfach hier vorne abschneiden,
ein bisschen hier vorne abschneiden
und gar nicht
– mit der Schale.
In der Schale steckt übrigens...
>> GÜNTER: Wieso sind die eingepackt
und die anderen nicht?
>> MURAT: Mal Gedanken machen.
So.
Ach!
Auf jeden Fall...
>> GÜNTER: Da, mach das mal weg.
>> MURAT: Manche Sache möchte man von...
>> GÜNTER: Mach das mal weg.
>> MURAT: Ja. Die möchte ich mir gar nicht ansehen bei dir.
So.
Genau. Siehst du? Das war jetzt intelligent.
Jetzt anstatt ein Würstchen zu nehmen. Verstehst du hier?
Weil, weißt, das war das erste Mal, wo ich merke,
der Typ denkt doch mit.
>> GÜNTER: Das habe ich von dir gesehen.
>> MURAT: Ja. Was?
>> GÜNTER: Das.
>> MURAT: Aha. Okay.
Danke schön, Güni.
Sag mal. Du bist gerade voll nett. Kann das sein?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall...
>> GÜNTER: Es kann sich halt ganz schnell wieder ändern.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
So. Während Güni...
>> GÜNTER: Der Schmerz ist schon im Anflug.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Während Güni hier die Würstchen schneidet
und die Karotten in Würfel macht,
mache ich mich an die Zwiebel ran.
Weil das Wichtige bei der Zwiebel ist einfach:
Du musst saumäßig schnell sein,
dass du nicht anfängst zu weinen.
Und da der Güni halt nicht gerade der Schnellste ist,
mache ich lieber die Zwiebel.
So.
Zwiebel schälen.
Auch wenn es eine Bio-Zwiebel ist, immer dran denken:
Zwiebeln immer schälen.
So.
Ich denke, was auch cool schmecken würde hier
– wobei, nee, eigentlich nicht.
Ihr könntet zum Beispiel auch rote Zwiebeln nehmen,
aber rote Zwiebeln schmecken eher roh.
Wusstest du das, Güni?
>> GÜNTER: Ja, weil das kommt von roh,
roh von rot.
[Rauschen]
Ja. Was mache ich jetzt mit den Geviertelten?
>> MURAT: Die machst du auch hier in die Ding rein bitte,
in die...
>> GÜNTER: Ja, klein schneiden noch.
>> MURAT: Ja, klein schneiden.
>> GÜNTER: In Würfel?
>> MURAT: Ja, es müssen jetzt nicht Würfel sein.
Also nicht so klein, muss nicht sein.
Die können schon ein bisschen bissfester sein.
>> GÜNTER: In Vierecke?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Kann es sein, dass du in der Geometrie gefehlt hast?
Oder kann es überhaupt sein,
dass du überhaupt in der Schule gefehlt hast?
[Musik]
Also jetzt habe ich die Zwiebeln geschnitten
– also geschält meine ich.
Eine ganz coole Geschichte jetzt.
Guck mal. Das geht viel, viel schneller,
als wenn der Güni das schneidet.
Vierteln oder halbieren, je nachdem, wie ihr es machen wollt.
>> GÜNTER: Doch nicht auf der Arb-
– auf dem Stein.
>> MURAT: So.
>> GÜNTER: Ah.
Auch rein.
Güni, guck mal.
Und einfach die Knoblauchzehen auch reinwerfen.
So.
Und jetzt
mach.
Zieh zweimal.
Zweimal.
Noch mal. Komm, mach noch mal.
Noch mal. Ach, mach noch mal.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, was jetzt?
Zweimal? Das war jetzt schon viermal.
>> MURAT: Ja, ich habe gesagt, in Zweierschritten,
das heißt zwei, zwei, noch mal zwei, zwei, noch mal zwei, zwei.
>> GÜNTER: So. Gut, oder?
>> MURAT: Na, noch mal.
So.
Eins,
zwei.
Reicht. Übertreib es nicht mit...
Hän-nänä-hän-nä-hän-nänänänän!
>> MURAT: Ja, mit ziehen lassen kennst du dich gut aus, gell?
[Tusch]
Da kennt er sich gut aus.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall, jetzt haben wir die Zwiebeln auch schon fertig.
Die lassen wir gerade hier drin.
Da nehmen wir gerade das Messer raus. Zack.
Zack.
Jetzt tust du die Kartoffeln
– die tust du auch noch so genau in die Stückchen...
Das kannst du machen.
Oder was du auch machen kannst,
das ist auch eine coole Idee.
Aber das ist, wie du willst.
Du kannst sie auch da reinmachen. Guck.
>> GÜNTER: Nee, ich mache das.
>> MURAT: Zack.
>> GÜNTER: Vierteln?
>> MURAT: Siehst du das?
>> MURAT: Siehst du das,
wie schnell das geht?
Bis du das gemacht hast...
[Gelächter]
Halt mal, du Depp!
>> GÜNTER: Hast du es noch nicht gemerkt?
>> MURAT: Halt mal kurz.
Güni, halte doch richtig.
>> GÜNTER: Du Arsch!
Der hat das Ding, glaube ich, zerstört.
Der hat das zerstört.
Das warst du selber.
>> MURAT: Weißt du was?
Weißt du, wovor ich Angst habe?
>> GÜNTER: Halt du das.
>> MURAT: Wenn du das Ding ziehst,
dass hinten was rauskommt.
Das ist das.
Genau das Gesicht hattest du.
Oh!
>> GÜNTER: Aber das wird rausgeschnitten.
Du bist ein Schwein!
>> MURAT: Aua!
[Gelächter]
Aua! Du bist so doof!
Das hat voll wehgetan! Weißt du das?
>> GÜNTER: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ich habe das voll blubbern gehört.
Kann es sein, dass deine Vorfahren in Barcelona
an diesem Turm, an diesem Gaudí-Turm da gearbeitet haben?
Wie lang hat der gedauert?
300 Jahre, bis die fertig waren?
Wie hieß die?
Wie hieß der? Gandhi?
Nee, Gaudí.
>> GÜNTER: Gandhi!
>> MURAT: Hieß der Gaudí, Josh?
Hieß der Gaudí?
>> GÜNTER: Nein, Gandhi.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ghandi, der war aus Indien.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Mahatmamahatma Gandhi.
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Wie hieß er? Wie hieß er?
>> MURAT: Mahatmamahat-
>> GÜNTER: Mamamama?!
>> MURAT: Ghandi.
Ja, das war Gaudí.
Das war ein Ding. Ein Architekten war das.
So. Jetzt mach ich das einfach an.
>> GÜNTER: Kennst du den Professor Lesch?
>> MURAT: Ja, Leschs Kosmos.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Du bist ja noch schlauer wie der Professor.
>> MURAT: Ist das ernst?
>> GÜNTER: Woher weißt denn du das alles?
>> MURAT: Ja. Das ist halt...
>> GÜNTER: Manchmal bin ich verblüfft.
>> MURAT: Das habe ich mir über die Jahre hin angeeignet.
Ja, durch...
>> GÜNTER: Angeeignet oder geklaut?
>> MURAT: Geklaut.
>> GÜNTER: Geklaut!
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
Langsam erhitzen.
So. Langsam erhitzen.
Jetzt brauche
– guck mal, hier nehme ich den.
Ich ziehe es raus und du nimmst ihn in die Hand, okay?
So mit einer Hand, okay?
>> GÜNTER: Ich fange es.
>> MURAT: Ja. Okay?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: So. Und dann nehmen wir einen Kochlöffel.
So.
Danke schön, Güni.
Und dann...
Habt ihr diesen Skill gesehen?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Weißt du was? Eigentlich müssten wir zwei in Ding auftreten?
>> GÜNTER: Im Zirkus?
>> MURAT: Nein, in Las Vegas.
Ja, Siegfried und Roy.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, du als einarmiger Bandit so.
Du bist ja klein. Weißt, so.
[Spielautomatengeräusche]
>> MURAT: Nein!
Siegfried und Roy, Güni und Murat.
>> GÜNTER: Du als der türkische einarmige Bandit.
>> MURAT: Ah ja?
Auf jeden Fall...
>> GÜNTER: Du könntest dann reich werden.
>> MURAT: Da warten wir gerade ein bisschen.
Genau.
Einen Topf niemals ohne Öl erhitzen. Ganz, ganz wichtig!
>> GÜNTER: Du hast den Herd aus.
>> MURAT: Doch, ich habe ihn auf 5.
Oh, das ist der falsche.
Du bist so doof! Du hast nur die Dinger eingeschaltet.
>> GÜNTER: Ach!
Ach! Aua!
Aua!
>> JOSH: Läuft jetzt der Herd?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JOSH: Oder nur die Lüftung?
>> MURAT: Nein, der Herd läuft.
>> GÜNTER: Gar nichts läuft.
>> MURAT: Ich merke es schon. So.
>> GÜNTER: Gar nichts. Der hat doch alles wieder ausgeschaltet.
>> MURAT: Jetzt Folgendes:
Genau. Güni, wir nehmen immer die gleichen Schüsseln.
Wir müssen nicht immer alles abspülen.
Warum?
>> GÜNTER: Nee.
>> MURAT: Weil wir Männer sind, gell?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, so ist es.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, gut,
ich bin ein Mann.
>> MURAT: Hm. Und was bin dann ich?
Weißt du, warum ich gerade so ein Ding habe?
Ich habe gerade voll den...
>> GÜNTER: Würgereiz?
>> MURAT: Nein, das sowieso den ganzen Tag schon,
seitdem du da bist.
Aber das kommt davon, wenn du das Olivenöl
– ich zeige dir mal was ganz kurz.
Warum es mir gerade so ein bisschen am Hals so kratzt,
das kommt daher.
Und zwar
– pass auf.
So.
Probier mal bitte.
>> GÜNTER: Aber nicht so viel.
>> MURAT: Das ist... Probier es.
>> GÜNTER: Ich kriege Durchfall.
>> MURAT: Es gibt nichts durch das Ding.
Das bekommst du auch morgens,
wenn du in den Spiegel schaust.
Da.
Pass auf. Jetzt sag mal ehrlich:
Kratzt es ein bisschen im Hals?
So ein bisschen Ding?
Gell, jetzt merkst du es?
[Trommelwirbel]
>> GÜNTER: Nee.
>> MURAT: Ehrlich nicht?
>> MURAT: Also kratzt es gar nicht im Hals oder so was?
>> GÜNTER: Nee.
>> MURAT: Weil ich habe die Oliven
mit meinen Füßen ausgepresst.
[Gelächter]
Weißt du was? Ich tu jetzt einfach...
Weißt du was? Wenn ich mit dir ab und zu rede,
denke ich einfach, ich rede mit einer Wand.
Weil das Problem ist, ich erzähle es dir
und ich weiß eh, das fällt auf der anderen Seite wieder raus.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, weil ich höre dir nicht...
Was soll ich jetzt sagen?
>> MURAT: Guck mal. Jetzt hat er schon aufgehört,
>> MURAT: weil er nicht mehr weiterweiß.
>> GÜNTER: Nein. Wie soll ich das sagen?
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt tun wir das Fleisch hier rein
und kurz anbraten.
>> GÜNTER: Ich mache ganz kurz.
>> MURAT: So.
>> MURAT: Du lügst
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> GÜNTER: zu oft.
>> MURAT: So.
>> GÜNTER: Du kannst ja jetzt hochdrehen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Kurz hochdrehen.
>> GÜNTER: Nicht kurz.
>> MURAT: Nicht scharf anbraten, einfach nur kurz...
>> GÜNTER: Doch, scharf anbraten.
>> MURAT: Nein. Röstaromen
– weißt du ab wie viel Grad Röstaromen entstehen?
Ich kann es euch ganz genau sagen:
137.
Das ist die Maillard-Reaktion.
137°C.
>> GÜNTER: Was für eine Reaktion?
>> MURAT: Maillard-Reaktion.
Du bist voll geplättet, gell?
Das ist...
Du bist echt voll geplättet.
Ich habe voll die Skills drauf inzwischen.
>> GÜNTER: Der Topf, wird der heiß?
>> MURAT: Nee.
Also, bis es am Griff ist, dauert es ein Weilchen.
Ich will es ja jetzt nur kurz scharf anbraten.
So.
Jetzt noch eine Frage.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob du das wusstest.
Weißt du, warum hier ein Loch drin ist?
Du hast aber nur eine Chance.
Also nicht irgendeinen Scheiß.
Weißt du, warum hier ein Loch drin ist?
>> GÜNTER: Dass sich es besser...
>> MURAT: Oder soll ich es dir erzählen?
>> GÜNTER: Dass sich es besser verteilt.
>> MURAT: Nein.
Jetzt überleg dir noch mal:
Warum ist hier ein Loch drin?
>> GÜNTER: Weniger Material.
>> MURAT: Nein, auch nicht.
Damit du durchgucken kannst.
Wie blöd kann man eigentlich sein?!
So. Jetzt weißt du es.
Ja.
Ah! Aua! Geh weg!
Und guck mal.
Und das Tolle an der ganzen Geschichte ist:
Der Güni hatte ja diese BiFi,
also die türkische BüFo reingeschmissen.
So. Auf jeden Fall, und jetzt merke ich,
wie sich die BiFi anbrennt.
Das ist wie so ein Röstaroma. Verstehst du, was ich meine?
>> GÜNTER: Mach mal deine Absaugung an.
>> MURAT: Guck mal.
>> GÜNTER: Ach so, das ist zu laut.
>> MURAT: Tu mir einen Gefallen. Jetzt riech mal kurz dran.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Nee. Hör auf!
>> GÜNTER: Hör auf!
>> MURAT: Ja. Jetzt riech mal kurz dran.
Guck mal. Obwohl ich jetzt noch keine Rostaromen erzeuge,
aber es riecht nach Rauch.
>> GÜNTER: Röst nicht Rost.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Rost ist doch was anderes wie Röst.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
Obwohl ich noch keine Röstaromen erzeuge,
aber es riecht wie Ding, gell?
Als ob ich es schon angeröstet hätte.
>> GÜNTER: Oder heißt es doch rösten?
>> MURAT: Ja. Und das ist genial.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, was jetzt? Heißt es Röst oder Rost?
>> MURAT: Röstaromen.
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Oder doch Rost?
>> MURAT: Roh.
>> GÜNTER: Die Einzahl, die Einzahl.
>> MURAT: Roh. Ja.
Ja.
Das reicht schon vollkommen.
Glaub mir.
So. Jetzt nehmen wir gerade das Fleisch.
So. Jetzt tust du es raus.
Los.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: So.
Perfekt.
>> GÜNTER: Du hast so starke Oberarme.
>> MURAT: Ist dir das aufgefallen?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Oh, Wahnsinn!
>> GÜNTER: Und da?
>> MURAT: Ja. Aua!
>> GÜNTER: Ja, dort nicht.
>> MURAT: So. Folgendes...
Perfekt!
Jetzt noch einen Schluck Olivenöl.
So.
Zack.
>> GÜNTER: Kommen die
– erst die?
>> MURAT: So.
Genau. Zwiebeln rein.
Genau. Pass auf. Nichts verschwenden, Güni.
>> GÜNTER: Oh! Das muss jetzt aber nicht sein.
>> MURAT: Warum?
So. Ich habe
– ich putze immer meine Hände.
>> GÜNTER: Die Kralle des Todes.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
So, Güni. Jetzt machen wir Folgendes.
Zwiebeln anbraten mit dem Knoblauch.
>> GÜNTER: Dann können wir die
>> MURAT: Oh, das riecht schon richtig toll!
>> GÜNTER: Kartoffeln und Karotten.
>> MURAT: So.
Die Zwiebeln nicht anbrennen.
Wirklich. Nicht anbrennen.
Das ist ein Riesenfehler, was du immer machst, anbrennen.
Weil dann werden sie bitter.
Das heißt, die Zwiebeln wirklich nur glasig,
schön glasig werden.
Und jetzt kommt der Trick dabei.
Jetzt noch Tomatenmark dreifach konzentriert rein.
Oh, das gibt...
Oh, das riecht einfach wahnsinnig!
So. Jetzt haben wir das Tomatenmark reingemacht, Güni.
So.
Riechst du das schon?
>> GÜNTER: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wahnsinn!
>> GÜNTER: Ich weiß nicht, ob das Tomatenmark ist
oder ob du es
– ob ich dich rieche. Ich weiß nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
So. Als Nächstes, Güni,
versuchen wir noch ein bisschen...
Genau. Eigentlich ist die Reihenfolge jetzt nicht mehr wichtig,
nur zuletzt das Ding.
So.
Genau.
Kartoffeln rein.
So. Und die Kartoffeln tun wir nicht anbrennen.
So.
Perfekt!
So. Güni, als Nächstes nehmen wir unser Wasser.
Das ist
– und zwar ganz, ganz wichtig:
>> GÜNTER: Das soll erst mal ein bisschen murkeln.
>> MURAT: Das Rezept funktioniert nur
mit dem guten alten Wiesentaler Wasser
aus dem Mineralbrunnen Wiesental.
So.
Weißt du, wofür wir das Wasser brauchen,Güni?
>> GÜNTER: Zum
>> MURAT: Damit die Kartoffeln...
>> GÜNTER: Garen.
>> MURAT: Genau, zum Garen.
Damit die Kartoffeln nachher drin sind. So.
Folgendes:
Tomaten. Was fällt dir hier ein bei Tomaten?
>> GÜNTER: Die können wir noch vierteln,
mit dem Messer gerade so ein bisschen klein schneiden.
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> GÜNTER: Guck.
>> MURAT: Die sind aus der Dose.
Ganz wichtig, Güni. Du bist der einzige Mensch,
der Tomaten aus der Dose vierteln würde.
>> GÜNTER: Ja?
>> MURAT: Die verteilen sich eh.
Das ist das Gleiche, als würdest du einfach
Cola durch ein Haarsieb machen,
damit du die Farbe Braun rauskriegst.
Mein Gott! Wie dumm kann man sein?! Das gibt es doch nicht!
>> GÜNTER: Das versuche ich immer.
>> MURAT: So.
Auf jeden Fall,
hier nehmen wir Tomaten auch mit rein.
Genau.
Guck mal. Das gibt eine richtige Suppe,
weil es ein cooler Eintopf ist.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Wie heißt der?
>> MURAT: Eintopf.
>> GÜNTER: Aber was für ein Eintopf?
>> MURAT: Das ist ein Holzfällereintopf.
>> GÜNTER: Aha.
>> MURAT: So.
Wobei man
– bei Holzfäller denkt man immer an den Wald.
Jetzt: Wo hast du im Wald jemals Karotten gefunden?
[Windgeräusche]
So. Auf jeden Fall...
Oder hast du da auch mal...
Warst du schon mal...
Hast du zu einem Kumpel mal gesagt:
"Hör mal zu, ich gehe heute in den Wald"
"Und was machst du dort?"
>> GÜNTER: "Karotten sammeln."
>> MURAT: "Kartoffeln ernten"?
>> GÜNTER: Karotten!
>> MURAT: Ja, Karotten sammeln und Kartoffeln ernten.
Genau, im Wald.
>> GÜNTER: Ah!
>> MURAT: Deswegen heißt das Ding Holzfäller.
Genau.
Oder hast du schon mal in...
Hast du schon mal...
Warst du schon mal im Wald
und bist durch den Wald gelaufen,
dann guckst du den Baum an und sagst:
"Oh, guck mal, oh, eine BiFi"?
>> GÜNTER: "Oh, ein Karottenbaum."
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
Ja. Oder stell dir vor, du läufst durch den Wald
und plötzlich ist da eine Kuh mittendrin.
Mitten im Wald ist eine Kuh.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, da war doch mal eine abgehauen in Bayern.
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
Die war sechs Wochen weg.
>> MURAT: Die Kuh?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ah! Das war ein Bär.
Das war keine Kuh.
>> GÜNTER: Das war eine Kuh.
>> MURAT: Das war der Problembär.
>> GÜNTER: Nein, das war...
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja. Den kennen...
>> GÜNTER: Das war eine Kuh!
>> MURAT: Die Älteren unter euch kennen das noch,
Problembär.
Ich sage nur Siegmund Stoiber.
>> GÜNTER: Wie macht eine Kuh?
>> MURAT: Muh.
>> GÜNTER: Und was reimt sich auf Muh?
>> MURAT: -rat.
Du bist so doof!
Ah!
So.
>> GÜNTER: Hör jetzt auf.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Jetzt können wir die Gewürze reinmachen.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Bei den Gewürzen machst du es je nach Geschmack.
>> GÜNTER: Die Lorbeerblätter.
>> MURAT: Lass mich das lieber machen.
Du hast nämlich keinen.
>> GÜNTER: Na gut. Da.
>> MURAT: Nee, war ein Spaß.
Mach rein.
>> GÜNTER: Alles rein?
>> MURAT: Ja, alles rein. Genau.
>> GÜNTER: Halt.
>> MURAT: Nachher können wir mal probieren.
Dann können wir noch ein bisschen mehr reinmachen.
Beim Kreuzkümmel immer aufpassen.
Der ist sehr, sehr geschmacksintensiv.
So.
Also alles rein.
Es sieht auch richtig toll aus schon.
Guck mal, Güni.
So.
Wie gesagt,
nachher dünstet das alles und schwitzt alles.
>> GÜNTER: Die Pilze sind jetzt etwas dicker geworden.
Haben die das Wasser aufgesogen?
>> MURAT: Ja, die haben das Wasser aufgesogen.
Deswegen. Das ist genau das.
>> GÜNTER: Hast du auch schon mal im Schwimmbad
das Wasser aufgesogen?
>> MURAT: Jetzt reicht es.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Jetzt stell mal richtig hoch da.
>> MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall – genau.
>> GÜNTER: Gib mal Gas.
>> MURAT: Genau. Ich mache jetzt mal ein bisschen Gas.
Genau, ein bisschen mehr, eine höhere Hitze.
Wir haben eine Stufe von 1 bis 10.
Ich bin jetzt momentan bei 8.
Genau.
Und jetzt ist ganz, ganz wichtig:
vor sich hinköcheln lassen
so ungefähr zehn Minuten.
Und nach diesen zehn Minuten
mache ich das Gulasch mit rein.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Pilze.
>> MURAT: Jetzt habe ich auf Stufe 8 gemacht.
Also wir haben zehn Stufen
und wir sind jetzt auf Stufe 8.
So. Dass es mal richtig heiß und warm wird.
Jetzt nehme ich das Fleisch.
Oh! Das riecht echt genial mit der BiFi, gell?
>> GÜNTER: Hm.
>> MURAT: Das ist Wahnsinn!
Also
zack.
>> GÜNTER: Sieht gut aus.
>> MURAT: Und eigentlich voll easy, gell?
So ein bisschen durchmischen.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Da ist definitiv zu wenig Flüssigkeit drin.
>> MURAT: Güni, da ist nicht zu wenig Flüssigkeit drin.
>> GÜNTER: Natürlich.
>> MURAT: Güni...
>> GÜNTER: Das muss doch alles garen.
>> MURAT: Güni, ich weiß es doch.
Aber das gart jetzt, glaub mir.
Und zwar, weißt du, woher ich das weiß?
Folgendes:
Du hättest recht, wenn das ein normaler Topf wäre.
>> GÜNTER: Aber?
>> MURAT: Aber wir haben einen Gusseisentopf,
einen Gusseisenbräter.
Jetzt tust du es hier rein
und jetzt kann keine Flüssigkeit mehr entweichen. Okay?
Du Dummbeutel.
So. Da drin ist es jetzt wie in einer Sauna.
Der Topf hat übrigens 5,5 Liter.
Ohne Spaß.
Also das heißt, wenn ihr dieses Rezept macht,
dann müsst ihr so einen Topf nehmen mit 5,5 bis 6 Litern,
also einen großen Topf.
Und so lassen wir es ungefähr eineinhalb bis zwei Stunden
so richtig cool schmoren.
Was ihr auch machen könnt, wenn ihr Bock drauf habt:
Ihr könnt zum Beispiel jetzt auch
– den Topf könnt ihr jetzt zum Beispiel
einfach in den Backofen reinmachen,
schön bei 160/170°C mal auch zwei Stunden drin lassen.
Das ist auch möglich, Güni.
Also, wenn man den Herd nicht anmachen möchte,
im Backofen.
Was ihr auch machen könnt, ist,
wenn ihr so einen Kugelgrill habt,
ihr nehmt einfach einen Kugelgrill,
könnt den Topf einfach
– den Gusseisentopf auf den Grill stellen,
Kugelgrill zumachen und da auch zwei, drei Stunden
schön köcheln lassen.
>> GÜNTER: Der verbrennt da nicht außen?
>> MURAT: Nein, da passiert gar nichts. Alles gut.
>> GÜNTER: Ist das Emaille?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Nein?
>> MURAT: Nein, das ist Gusseisen.
Ja, das ist emailliertes Gusseisen.
Und warum habe ich das gemacht?
Weil ich
nachgedacht habe.
>> GÜNTER: Aha.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und das ist genau das, was dich,
den Menschen vom...
>> GÜNTER: Was uns unterscheidet.
>> MURAT: Was uns unter-
Also es unterscheidet den Menschen und das Tier.
Der Mensch denkt immer vorausschauend.
Das Tier denkt immer an das Jetzt.
Außer die Eichhörnchen.
>> GÜNTER: Und du bist halt auch ein Eichhörnchen.
>> MURAT: Ja, so ist es.
So.
O mein Gott!
Irgendwie manchmal denke ich...
Liebe Kinder, wenn ihr das hier anschaut,
nehmt das nicht immer alles ernst, was wir machen.
Wir sind eigentlich sehr, sehr gute Freunde.
Auch wieder gelogen.
Aber egal.
Nehmt das nicht immer alles ernst, was wir zueinander sagen.
Wir mögen uns eigentlich.
Und wir zeigen es nur weniger.
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Mm-m-m-mm-m!
>> MURAT: Eineinhalb Stunden später.
[Musik]
Auf jeden Fall, jetzt sind wir fertig.
Wir haben das jetzt ungefähr zwei Stunden
wirklich auf dem Herd gehabt.
Wie gesagt, ihr könnt es auf dem Grill machen
oder im Backofen, wie ihr es möchte.
Das geht mit einem Gusseisentopf immer.
So.
Jetzt
werden wir mal probieren.
So.
Ein bisschen durchrühren.
Und ihr merkt eigentlich
– also es kommt darauf an,
wie groß ihr das Fleisch geschnitten habt,
wie groß ihr die Kartoffeln geschnitten habt.
Wenn ihr merkt
– die Kartoffeln sind eh durch, 100 Prozent.
Wenn ihr
– das Fleisch muss richtig zart sein.
Das heißt, wenn es noch nicht so richtig zart ist,
einfach noch ein bisschen länger köcheln.
Guckt wirklich aufs Fleisch.
Ja.
Du hast ja nicht aufs Fleisch geguckt.
Deswegen hast du ja auch so viel.
So.
Auf jeden Fall,
natürlich haben wir einen Testesser.
Wir tun ja keine Kosten und Mühen sparen und laden...
>> GÜNTER: Scheuen.
>> MURAT: Scheuen. Entschuldigung.
Sparen. Ich denke immer als Schwabe, sparen.
>> GÜNTER: Ha ja. Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, scheuen.
Und wir haben natürlich auch einen Gast eingeladen,
der gerade hier bei uns war.
Und zwar ist das der Fatih abi.
Fatih abi ist Journalist,
ist in einer
– arbeitet bei einer Tageszeitung,
[Jubel]
kommt aus der Türkei. Richtig?
>> FATIH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau.
Er spricht ein bisschen Deutsch,
aber ein gutes Englisch.
>> FATIH: Ja.
>> MURAT: We can speak in English if you want.
>> FATIH: Englisch, deutsch, türkisch.
>> MURAT: No problem?
>> FATIH: No problem.
>> MURAT: Güni was...
>> GÜNTER: You're a very intelligent little boy.
>> MURAT: Darf ich mich gerade kurz
in den Kopf hier übergeben? Mein Gott, he!
So. Auf jeden Fall war Güni...
>> GÜNTER: Ich kann auch Englisch.
>> MURAT: Güni was in Winnipeg in Canada
>> FATIH: Okay.
>> GÜNTER: Military time.
>> MURAT: – military – about
– since 20
– nee, 50 years ago.
50 years ago, ja?
>> GÜNTER: 40, ja.
>> MURAT: In military, ja?
>> FATIH: Is he Canadian?
>> MURAT: No, he is a wombat.
>> FATIH: Oh!
>> MURAT: He is a wombat.
>> GÜNTER: No, no.
>> MURAT: Ja.
This is
Turkish
ormancı kebabı.
>> FATIH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Auf Türkisch.
>> MURAT: In English
– was heißt denn Förster auf Englisch?
Lumberjack.
>> MURAT: Richtig?
>> GÜNTER: Was?
>> MURAT: Jäger?
>> GÜNTER & JOSH: Holzfäller.
>> MURAT: Holzfäller heißt lumberjack, gell?
Oh, my English is good, ja?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> FATIH: It's very good.
>> MURAT: Oh, good.
You can...
Jetzt sagst du nichts mehr, gell?
Wenn andere Englisch sprechen, hältst du's Maul.
>> GÜNTER: You are a very intelligent
>> MURAT: Ja, danke schön.
Das hat er sich gemerkt.
>> GÜNTER: little boy.
>> MURAT: Ja, okay.
I hope you like it.
>> FATIH: Yeah, I'm sure.
It seems very nice.
>> MURAT: So.
>> FATIH: You first.
>> GÜNTER: Nein, nein.
>> FATIH: Here.
>> GÜNTER: You, you.
>> FATIH: Okay.
>> GÜNTER: You.
You're the first one.
>> MURAT: Ja.
So.
>> FATIH: Okay.
Let's try it.
>> MURAT: Try it.
Iss du mal nicht so viel.
Du hast nicht gerade Ding.
>> GÜNTER: Ich wäre ruhig an deiner Stelle.
>> MURAT: So.
Bread please
if you want.
>> FATIH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Hauptschule 9. Klasse Englisch-Leistungskurs
bei Frau Lange.
>> FATIH: Sehr schön.
>> MURAT: Sehr schön? Gefällt dir es wirklich?
>> FATIH: Ja, sehr schön.
>> MURAT: Weil, wenn es nicht schmecken würde,
wäre eh der Güni schuld.
Ja.
That's a...
That's a mix
about Turkish and German food.
>> FATIH: Ja. But is this Turkish food?
>> MURAT: Turkish, yes.
>> FATIH: Ja?
>> MURAT: Yeah.
>> GÜNTER: Salami, Turkish Salami.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
>> GÜNTER: Da fehlt ein bisschen Knoblauch und Salz.
>> FATIH: Hm.
>> MURAT: Çok güzel değil mi?
>> FATIH: Harika!
>> MURAT: Harika!
>> FATIH: Wirklich schön.
>> MURAT: Fatih abi bu adam bir şey bilmiyor
durum adam...
Aha!
Ich sage ihm jetzt alles auf Türkisch,
sage ich, dass du es nicht verstehst.
So.
Ama gelsin, güzel değil mi?
>> FATIH: The meat is well-cooked.
>> MURAT: Yes?
>> FATIH: Çok lüks. It's very nice. Really.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> FATIH: It's delicious!
Der hat gesagt: "The meat is well-cooked."
Also das heißt, das Fleisch ist schon
>> GÜNTER: gut gekocht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Nein, nicht nur das. Er hat auch gesagt:
"Der Typ neben mir, der riecht ein bisschen komisch",
hat er gesagt.
Ja. Ja.
Der hat aber dich damit gemeint.
>> FATIH: In Turkish we say:
"Eline sağlık!"
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> FATIH: It's really nice.
Thank you.
>> MURAT: Ja. Er hat gesagt,
er will dich nie mehr wieder sehen.
Ja.
Okay.
Auf jeden Fall
hat mir es echt Spaß gemacht,
heute mit euch zusammen zu kochen.
Mit...
Es war mir eine Ehre mit dir, Fatih abi, dass du hier warst.
Wir machen einen coolen...
>> FATIH: Ich danke auch.
>> MURAT: Ja?
Cool. Dann machen wir einen coolen Zeitungsbericht.
Du darfst türkisches Hoheitsgebiet nicht mehr betreten jetzt
nach diesem Video.
Na?
>> GÜNTER: Okay.
>> MURAT: Warum?
>> GÜNTER: Weil du den Präsidenten beleidigt hast.
>> MURAT: Ich sage es dir!
>> GÜNTER: Du!
>> MURAT: So.
Auf jeden Fall macht's gut. Macht's besser.
Euer Güni. Euer Fatih.
Tschüss!
>> GÜNTER: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Cool, Güni.
Guck mal. Der haut schon ab.
Guck mal. Der hat die Schnauze voll von dir.
Hast du gesehen?
Fatih abi, nimm es mit.
>> FATIH: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Noch ein bisschen Salz fehlt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja.
Der will nie mehr wiederkommen, hat er gesagt.
>> GÜNTER: Hm, hm.
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Super, he!
Ehrlich!
>> GÜNTER: Noch ein bisschen Salz
und noch ein bisschen Pfeffer.
>> MURAT: Ja, ein bisschen Pfeffer und Salz.
Also ich muss ehrlich...
>> GÜNTER: Das muss man abschmecken, wie man es will.
>> MURAT: Das muss man echt sagen:
Du bist nicht so dumm, wie du aussiehst. Kennst du das?
>> GÜNTER: Das Blatt kannst du ruhig mitessen.
>> MURAT: Nee.
>> GÜNTER: Das ist gesund.
>> MURAT: Mhm.
Bist du blöd, oder?
Nur, weil du im Wald lebst,
muss man ja nicht jedes Blatt essen, oder?
>> GÜNTER: Der frisst wirklich das Lorbeerblatt!
Ich kotze ab! Ich kotze ab!
Der will das
– er hat das Lorbeerblatt raus.
Da habe ich gesagt: "Das kannst du ruhig mitessen."
"Einen Moment."
Und dann...
Ich kann nicht mehr!
Kann man so blöd sein?
Meine Fresse!
[Musik]